[Music]
everybody was against me at that time
because nobody believed in women
empowerment and self-defense but I
proved everybody wrong
I started she fighter because one of my
colleagues at the University
she was dealing with domestic violence
all the time in her home so I decided to
train women how to defend themselves
from different types of violence and to
put an end to violence against women
first of all they gained self-confidence
second of all they gave physical
confidence so in order for women to
protect themselves and defend themselves
they have to start by building up their
self-esteem it's really great to see
girls come in a little bit shy and
unsure and like they tell you their
stories and like some of the issues that
they have at home around the streets
here and then you know you just watch
their confidence build and grow as you
teach them
[Music]
I faced lots of you know challenges to
start that software in Jordan because
you know men and women they don't like
the idea of women empowerment in our
society they want to keep the tradition
and the culture you know in their hands
[Music]
in order to expand our system and reach
out to rural areas and Syrian refugees
what we do we train trainers in
different areas and we send them to
these patients and they've sought
training other women and students there
in that case we reach more women and we
empower better the society
[Music]